good afternoon and welcome to at Yale
live I'm Eric Kershaw the human
population is rising many natural
resources are dwindling our planet is
warming and changing in ways that
threaten life and ways of life joining
us today to discuss the environment is
Peter crane Dean of the Yale School of
Forestry and environmental studies he is
also former director of Chicago's Field
Museum and the author of the new book
ginkgo the tree that time forgot Peter
thanks for being with us pleasure great
to be here so so many of the
environmental problems that we face are
of course interrelated can be tough to
distinguish one from another the impact
of one on another a little bit what do
you think are two or three environmental
problems that are most pressing in your
view as Peter crane I think I think you
have to kind of admit that climate
change is a huge issue because it
affects just about everything else and
the temperature the planet the patterns
of precipitation these are absolutely
key but sort of underneath those
underneath that broader issue I that's
kind of the fundamental human needs
which are energy food water these are
not things that we can opt out of and so
climate change will have an impact on
all of those issues but then within
those issues there are a lot of
specificities that also need to to be
dealt with how will we meet our energy
needs how will we meet food production
needs without taking up yet more land
and destroying more habitat and how will
we meet our needs for for water when
we're already using water in a huge way
both on the energy front and in
agriculture as well as for direct human
use so these problems are interconnected
the climate change piece over arches the
whole thing but then there are a lot of
other issues besides so given that any
one of these given that all of them are
important and a tan
given time one might seem more important
than another how do those of you who are
engaged full-time in the exploration of
the environment about prioritizing them
well I think it's not so much a question
of prioritizing but they all because
they all need attention I think the most
important thing and the point that we
try to get across to our students is
that one does need to understand the
interconnections among them because I
think otherwise there's a huge potential
for sort of making mistakes and so you
know biofuels I think is a great example
I mean at some level but you will seem
like a sensible solution to to our
energy needs and so we put in place
legislation without really thinking
through what the deeper consequences of
that legislation might be in terms of
its effect on food prices in terms of
its effect on land use and so on so one
of the things that we like to kind of
get across to our students is to think
critically about these issues and to
think broadly about these issues one of
my faculty members said yesterday that
you know we liked we like to give our
students breath because that's that's
how they excel but we also like to give
our students depth because that's how
they get a job and I think I think that
that's kind of a good way to think about
it and interconnectedness is not just
with respect to one environmental or
ecological issue and another but also as
you point out in raising the issue of
food prices and biofuels economics and
Urban Development and absolutely and
human behavior and I think you know one
of the things that we've we've we've
learned from the whole trajectory of the
climate debate is that you have to have
people in the picture and once you put
people in the picture that means
politics it means economics it means
jobs and unless you're connected to
those issues
the science by itself is not going to
get enough traction so speaking of
people climate change gets a fair amount
of attention within universities in the
media do you think there's a sufficient
sense of urgency within society at large
whether that society is a particular
nation or the world at large I think
that in fact the school we have a
project on climate change communications
turn into Sarah wet sand and his work
that's kind of looking at the way people
in not only in the u.s. think about
climate change but also how people in
india and china for example think about
climate change and i think it is
increasingly penetrating people's
consciousness and it does that in in
complicated ways and i think different
segments of the population respond to
different elements of the climate change
discussion but you know here in here in
New England we've had a succession of
unusual climate events and when that
kind of thing happens that raises public
awareness and they start to wonder maybe
these some of these things are linked
it's just having a conversation with an
alum who lives in Denver you know the
the ski business let alone the water
business is already noticing the
difference it's just not as much snow
during those the holiday period that has
a direct impact on their business that
was the most important time of the year
for them so people are beginning to see
these changes and as they do it starts
to raise I think the questions in their
mind that this might all be connected to
this overarching theme that people have
been talking about now to some time so I
gather that you perceive it that as
people are paying more attention as a
sense of urgency they might be building
but it doesn't seem like there's really
a people perceive it as a crisis at this
point and often times it takes
perception of a crisis to get
institutions
whether it's government or business or
individuals to take meaningful
consequential action yeah and I think we
see this so often in many different
facets of of life that we do respond to
the crisis but then there's the question
to of how long the crisis lasts and I
think you know if there's a kind of a
general problem that we have it's it's
an inability to take the long view
mm-hmm and and in a way that's natural
where we're a species that that lives in
the present like like close relatives do
but one of the things that we have that
distinguishes us from other primates is
this ability to think more deeply and to
look a little way into the future and
understand something about the
consequences of our actions the problem
is that that very often these
consequences seem to be too far away to
really worry about then we have a crisis
we pay attention for a while and then
eventually it subsides but i think you
know these issues are not going to go
away this is not a passing a problem
that's that's that that will be gone in
a decade or two all of these issues
climate water food energy these are
going to be pressing issues for a
growing human population with increasing
expectations and higher levels of
consumption that at the moment we can
barely see the end of you know we're
heading to 10 billion or more people in
pretty pretty short order and yet the
build-up to this sense of crisis is
gradual but one of the challenges it
seems is that once we reach true crisis
it would be too late to take action that
would save us well I think that like
many things money counts for a lot so
the burden of these in these areas will
always thought fall on the people least
able to respond to it
the people who have the money the
countries that have the money will be
able to adapt and we'll be able to at
some level buy their way out of the
problem but the the pain will fall
disproportionately on on the poor and
those those who find it who don't have
the resources to adapt so well let me
take a question from a viewer this is
from my new Rob and the question is what
what alternative energy source or
sources do you think has the greatest
potential to substitute for fossil fuels
and what are some of the issues that are
likely to come up or will come up should
we achieve some kind of transition or as
we attempt to transition well I think
you know this this air has changed quite
a lot recently particularly with the the
kind of gas boom and the question I
think is you know is that good for the
environment or not is it good for the
economy or not we'll also will also
factored into it but we have available
to us now an increasing source of cheap
natural gas and what are the
environmental consequences of that and
indeed what are the broader consequences
of that in terms of the development of
cleaner energy sources will those lower
prices basically remove the incentive to
develop solar geothermal technologies
wind technologies and and so on so i
think that's that's kind of one set of
issues how we kind of move to those
cleaner technologies and whether the
natural gas Bonanza is is helpful as a
bridge or unhelpful in the sense that it
will stifle the development of those
technologies and then also looming in
the background and again it's largely a
matter of price but also environmental
considerations is is what role will
nuclear power play in the future which
as we know
has great some great benefits in terms
of co2 but also significant associated
problems yeah so do you view natural gas
and nuclear as the most likely
alternatives to fossil the materialistic
one I think they're very very different
i think in the short term i think it's
going to be very difficult to to get
people off this natural gas a phenomenon
i think in reality so i think the
short-term need is to make sure that
that the fracking is done responsibly
and done well striking a hydraulic
fracture hydra hydraulic fracturing so
that's done well with minimal impact on
the environment although obviously there
will be some and at the same time I
think there needs to be a broader policy
discussion about how we stimulate the
development of cleaner energy
technologies I'm glad you brought up you
know policy discussions because I wanted
to ask obviously academics people who
study say the environment full-time in a
very serious way are among the most
informed people in our society on
whatever the topic is that they study is
there a role for what is the proper role
i guess i would ask in your view of
academics in the policy debate is there
is there a point at which they should be
careful not to become too involved in
the political aspect of it should they
remain exclusively advisers and
researchers or do you think that they
should be directly involved in taking
political stance on some of these issues
I think there's a this room for a
plurality of approaches and I think a
lot of that will depend on the
individual themselves and you know we
have seen great examples of individual
scientists getting involved and and and
actually producing meaningful policy
that change so I think that that is you
know there is a role for that but I
I think the key is to make sure that the
science and the analysis is right and is
solid and then if it is solid I think
that I think that that scientists have
that option and some may feel it's a
duty to make sure that people understand
the situation and I think that was the
case with sherry Rowland and and and the
ozone layer I think many of the
scientists involved in the climate
change debate feel they have a
responsibility to make the consequences
of their results clearly known and of
course that happens in many other areas
too but it's really important that the
science is well done peer reviewed
absolutely solid because once that once
that goes I think you are on very shaky
foundations let me take another question
from the viewers and this is from asiah
why is it so hard for developed
countries and there's a premise embedded
in this question why is it so hard for
developed countries to adopt
environmental protections and I guess I
would add to that you one might also ask
why is it so hard in in fully developed
countries to do that I think that you
know when you look back even in my
lifetime so the quality environment has
changed quite a bit and in some respects
has changed for the better in many
countries in the developed world because
they've understood the importance of
putting in pollution control measures
understood the importance of putting in
place the right kinds of policies so if
you look at air quality inn in not all
but many North American cities it's
better than it used to be certainly
that's the case in the UK if you look at
the water quality it's better than it
used to be and some developing countries
are on a similar trajectory but some
some way behind the developed world the
problems they're having with air
pollution in in Beijing right now very
reminiscent of the problems
london had in the 1950s so i'm sure that
that that they will get there but as the
chinese government thinks about these
things it's got many different
priorities to balance but i know for a
fact that they are putting in the right
kinds of environmental legislation but
it's takes some time and it's going to
take some time to get it in force just
as it just as it did in britain in the
1950s what is the your view the relative
the relative roles for government and
play industry and and perhaps even
individuals in addressing some of the
problems we face this is good government
be the primary driver should industry
should do we really need to take
individual responsibilities at the at
the individual level to make any
meaningful change i think i think
obviously all three have a
responsibility governments I think have
a responsibility to create the right
kind of policies that move society in a
sensible direction with regard to
environmental stewardship and
sustainability I think companies are
increasingly interested in these issues
for a whole variety of reasons not just
their license to operate and the and the
defensive posture of escaping
environmental regulation but also from
from the standpoint of ensuring
continuity of their business operations
ensuring the continuity of their their
raw materials so as these problems begin
to bite I think you will see and I think
you're already seeing greater interest
from the business community in these
environments I heard one chief executive
of a major u.s. corporation express it
this way a few months ago think about
the changing role of the sustainability
officer once the sustainability officer
was at the periphery just taking care of
a whole bunch of compliance issues many
companies now the sustainability officer
is actually at the center of the company
close to the chief executive advising
him or her on how the company should
respond to these environmental
another question this one from Scott and
this one is a little technical but i'll
ask anyway how will how will climate
change affect the spatial distance
between the Earth and the Sun or the
eccentricity of Earth's orbit around the
Sun I have to say this one I hadn't
contemplated before but well I think
what sort of being referred to there is
is if you look at the kind of macro
scale climatic change over the last
several million years it's very clear
that the sort of glacial and
interglacial cycles are driven by all
the changes in three key orbital
parameters but in it so there's there's
a clear role of planetary factors in
long-term climate change but what we're
seeing here is a totally different order
of a totally different time scale you
know we're seeing a rapid buildup of co2
in the atmosphere that has clear and
demonstrable changes and we're seeing it
happen extremely rapidly compared to
these 10,000 year hundred thousand years
sort of geological cycles so this is a
kind of a different problem but it's
it's certainly part of the overall
climate change picture but i think it's
not relevant to what's happening here
and now and has happened in the last 50
years or the last 200 years question
about education environmental education
there aren't that many schools that i
know of in the united states that are
have a free-standing schools of the
environment within them does that seem
to be changing our schools are we seeing
new schools of the environment crop up I
think that's an interesting question I
think we're very lucky here at Yale
because we had a forestry school that's
over a hundred years old and over time
that school is adapted and changed and
respond to a whole range of broader
environmental issues not solely forestry
now but but climate water energy policy
economics and and and so on so I think
we're very fortunate in that regard and
other universities that we certain
have some great environment schools at
other universities of Duke Michigan at
Santa Barbara and so on but at many
universities the environment sort of
falls in the interstices between
traditional departments and that I think
is a problem the geology department owns
a bit of this issue the biology
department owns a bit of this issue the
economics department owns a bit of this
issue so for many universe is the
challenge is how to put together a
credible environmental curriculum that
crosses multiple units with within the
academic institution and that's often
harder than it should be and I think for
a really integrated program to happen
that's good that's quite a that's quite
a challenge but but you are seeing
universities respond because first the
issues are central to society now and
second because their central to society
there's increased student demand
students are interested in these issues
student wants students want to learn
about these issues and so universities
somehow have to figure out how to
respond and it's not just students who
are interested in becoming climate
scientists either or even scientists at
all necessarily absolutely because as
I've said these issues affect every
aspect of society they're working their
way increasingly into every aspect of
our daily lives this is an important
issue for the future let's talk about a
project of yours you've recently
published a new book called ginkgo tell
us about the ginkgo tree and how you got
interested in it and why I decided to
write a book about it well this this in
a way was was kind of a little piece of
fun for me although it's it turned into
a to a much larger project than I'd
hoped it's about a particular tree and
but the book really in the book really
is a kind of a particular species of
tree particular species their
distinctive species of tree one of the
most common street trees in Asia and for
example here in in the Connecticut in
Manhattan it's one of the comments
street trees but it has a wonderful
story to tell it has a deep evolutionary
history it has a deep and complicated
cultural history so in a way the book is
an evolutionary and cultural biography
of a tree but at the same time it gives
me the opportunity to talk about some of
these environmental issues and to
reflect on them one of the questions
that it brings up is this whole issue of
time you know we've been talking about
time you know in my lifetime in a little
over 50 years the global population is
more than doubled its gone from three to
seven billion in the last 50 years so we
inevitably focus on these short time
frames but in the grand history of our
planet in the 4.6 billion year history
of our planet or even the 200 million
year plus history of the ginkgo tree
this is a short time span so part of
this book was to ask people particularly
the last few chapters as well ask people
to kind of reflect on time and to
reflect on our our brief 10 years brief
10 years on this planet and think about
the long view to try to take the long
view instead of the short view all of
the time now the correct me if I'm wrong
and I know you will ginkgo tree did it
almost get wiped out and then rebounded
yeah and another reason why I wanted to
write this story is that this is
actually a kind of a good news story and
once I was looking for us for something
that's a good news story I mean this
this was a tree that was widespread for
millions of years across our planet
lived on every continent but almost went
extinct over the last few million years
and exists today as wild populations
possibly in just two locations in in
China so in a way the fact that we still
have ginkgo around and the fact that we
now know it and we can see it and enjoy
it is really because of the relationship
of that tree to people and this it's
people that have spread that plant
around the world and I think it's kind
of fascinating
to think that all of those ginkgos that
you see on the campus here in New Haven
or in Manhattan or San Francisco or
Tokyo all come from those two wild
populations in China so in part the
cultural biography is about the human
relationship with this particular tree
and I think you can argue that it's a
species that humans have saved rather
than driven to extinction elaborate on
that over by spreading it by spreading
it and so obviously the most important
thing is to conserve species where they
live and where they grow in the natural
ecosystems of which they are part but I
think we're fortunate indeed to have
many plant species and many animal
species to still available for us to
love and understand and study because we
have learned how to cultivate them so
for me another message in this book is
that conservation through cultivation is
an important way that we will we will
look after plants in the future and
indeed you know this this is a broader
trend you know with so much of the
Earth's surface already dramatically
changed by people we have to find homes
for native plants and animals in
human-dominated landscapes and we often
need to intervene to make sure that
happens and that's the only way that
many of these species are going to
survive this reminds me of this brings
to mind urbanization again and of course
China is still developing very fast many
of the biggest cities of the future may
the biggest current cities are in China
but most of the Urban Development i'm
not mistaken anticipate in the next
century or so is expected in in asia and
china doesn't have the strongest
environmental record too to what extent
do you think there's room for the rest
of the world to bring the attention
bring make it a priority for the chinese
i think actually it's already a priority
for them but they're juggling multiple
priorities
and they understand the bird the
environmental burdens that they will
face if they can't get to grips with
these issues that they're facing the
challenge of a very large population so
I think that they understand but in a
way they have the same problems that we
do getting things done sometimes is a
problem he even here in the even here in
the US but I think there's a there's a
broader issue about urbanization that
I'd kind of like to mention it and that
is as the world's population now more
than fifty percent of the global
population lives in urban areas as that
happens I think a really important
question is to what extent will people
lose the connection that they had with
nature when they lived in rural
environments that may not have always
been a happy connection for them but
people were always aware of their
connect their connection to the natural
world think one of the bigger dangers in
in urbanization is that people lose that
sense of connection with the natural
world and therefore take it for granted
and you can see this in the smallest
ways where the kids in in the inner-city
don't know where their vegetables come
from or don't know where that milk comes
from but you also see it in the sense
that that do they care about the the
plants that are in their environment
what is their relationship to animals
how do they think about their the
natural world I think this is a
challenge with urbanization because you
know sophisticated and as urbanized as
we might be opting out of photosynthesis
and our relation to plants for food
opting out of clean water opting out of
clean air opting out of energy opting
out of living within a certain
temperature band is not an option
actually so the question is how will
people think about these issues when
then connections to the natural world
become ever more tenuous in the way that
they think about it in their daily lives
so in a sense nature in cities and
around cities is is disproportionately
important for the future well this is a
great topic for us to
up up on actually let me ask you this
how do you peter crane keep in touch
with nature as you're shuttling around
the world as an educator and ambassador
of the environment I love to be out so
this weekend took a walk up to the top
of east rock Aaron here in New Haven I
was in California the previous weekend
and had a wonderful trip out into the
Mojave deserts or the saw the Joshua
trees which I've never seen before saw
some wonderful little annual plant some
of which were no no bigger than this but
are perfectly adapted to living life in
these desert situations I just think
there's there's huge wonder in in the
variety of life on this planet and for
me that's a really important thing and i
hope to 44 others in the world that's an
important way for them to think of the
sort of splendor of the natural world
not only what it does for us what it can
do for us but how it inspires us and it
ending riches our lives peter crane it's
been a pleasure chatting with you today
thanks for joining us thanks to all of
you for watching join us again for the
next episode of at Yale live next month